es el primer encuentro en 5 años al
menos de público entre un primer
ministro israelí y el rey de jordania la
reunión en ammán entre ella y rápida y
abdulá segundo fue larga y cálida según
el gobierno israelí ambos coincidieron
en la importancia de la reciente visita
del presidente de estadounidense joe
biden a la región pero las conclusiones
divulgadas por ambos se fueron
diferentes en su comunicado la casa real
jordana reiteró su defensa de una
solución de dos estados para el
conflicto palestino-israelí e instó a
incluir a los palestinos en los
proyectos de desarrollo y seguridad
regionales este aspecto fue omitido en
la declaración del gobierno hebreo que
optó por destacar las oportunidades de
cooperación entre los países con énfasis
en algunos proyectos en marcha en acceso
al agua energía solar seguridad
alimentaria y transporte aunque israel
ya provee de agua dulce a jordania
también busca vender agua desalinizada
mientras que jordania reclama a israel
que relaje los controles sobre las
exportaciones a cisjordania ocupada por
otro lado el rey jordano llamó a
mantener la calma y respetar el status
quo de jerusalén y sus lugares sagrados
en el período venidero cuando se
celebran las festividades judías
jordania es guardián de la explanada de
las mezquitas un espacio reservado al
culto musulmán al que en los últimos
meses han accedido judíos rezando y
cantando lo que es considerado una
provocación por los palestinos